ils sont de plus en plus nombreux à
dénoncer le petit monde hypocrite qu'est
la télévision c'est une forme d'être
humain qui est pourri de l'intérieur
quoi ils sophie davant maintenant à
l'antenne depuis plus de 30 ans n'a fait
que confirmer les rumeurs lors d'un
entretien accordé à télé star
l'animatrice a expliqué que l'émission à
faire conclut qu'elle anime depuis 2010
est avait été une véritable bouffée
d'air pour elle ça me change de
l'univers de la télé qui n'est qu'un
monde d'ego et d'éphémère là c'est tout
le contraire en 2020 il avait déjà donné
sa vision de cet univers plus reluisant
à gala trop de jalousie de rivalités de
jean surfer alors la télévision un monde
d'ego et d'éphémère êtes vous d'accord
avec les propos de sophie davant
castaldi oui oui oui
après y'a pas que des gens qui sont
fondées mais c'est vrai que il ya
tellement d'enjeux en fait été vendus et
les plats sont tellement cher que ça ça
crée des tensions très fortes vous
prenez l'on va pas se mentir tout le
monde c'est vrai que des gens ne disent
pas les choses voilà aider j'en ai
jamais les gens ça que les gens moi
comme je suis assez front où il en a vu
avec les sauces même avec les autres oui
on n'est pas le secret voilà c'est ça
non mais c'est pour ça que j'ai j'ai pas
que des amis voilà ce que je dis les
choses je préfère dire les choix moi
j'ai fait ça que j'ai fait comme vous
mais voilà mais jamais mais j'avais
moins de pouvoir sûrement ça m'a coûté
beaucoup plus cher mais
c'est vrai que c'est vrai que dire ce
qu'on pense à la touraine et marées dire
ce qu'on pense aux gens qui vous emploie
que terra ça peut avoir des conséquences
parfois compliqué c'est vrai mais par
contre on fait des belles rencontres sur
le terrain ils vont être la preuve sans
merci doit aussi rencontrer mais tu n'as
pas besoin de sucer la poire
[Rires]
benali
hypocrite comme dans tout en revanche
mandé go fm erwin ego parce qu'on passe
à la télé donc évidemment que c'est
toujours si les têtes et des têtes comme
sa coiffe cd melon énorme quoi et
éphémère parce que nous sommes des
produits périssables il n'y a que nous
qui connaissons pas la date de
péremption mais à moi je la connais pour
vous
mais en revanche voilà il ya des propos
pour les pour on peut aussi faire des
très belles rencontres je l'avais dit
ici et oui il ya des gens très bien
aussi bien sûr qu'il ya des gens bien et
gilles verdez non non c'est trop parce
que vous avez connu que nous sommes
exactement dans un monde de bisounours
abri on est d'accord mais ici j'ai
allait prendre l'exemple justement d'ici
ici que l'on soit là ou pas moi si
j'étais plus là tous ces gens là par
quelques-uns je continuerai à leur
écrire à être oui mais voudrait prendre
non mais il ya des liens très forts qui
se créent mais c'est vrai paroxystique
mais les liens sont aussi très très fort
et donc ses délires qui sont indélébiles
qu'on soit encore présent ou pas donc je
dis non isabelle oui c'est paroxystique
non c'est pas raciste icc vous et c'est
vrai je suis entièrement d'accord mais
ce que vient de dire valérie c'est vrai
qu'il ya des belles rencontres mais cvc
pire ce qui n'est pas dit par exemple la
france télévisions quand les gens
apprennent qu'ils sont virés toujours
parle par la danse à la presse par jour
y voilà enfin en guise et bernard vous
qui avait été justement moi je ne peux
pas me reprocher ça moi j'ai tellement
été honnête je sais que ça tient mon
temps mon tienne il a dit les choses et
l'évier et pour le pour ça je te
respecte avis mais voilà ce que vous
avec l'armée franchement avec des
munitions relève fort tard mais quel
décor connaissent comme des pastels
avait un super salaires sont plus bas
jamais eu ras-le-bol et j'ai balancé sur
skis j'ai envie de balancer bien sûr tu
as bien fait dans lesquels j'ai eu envie
de balancer y passer bon margaret pas du
tout mais sur qu'est-ce qu'on a plutôt
réussi à jeter les à-coups dit en
rajouter quoi qu'est-ce qu'on en a à
[ __ ] et épanoui ici mais j'ai très
peur pour l'argent -
va très bien tu viendras bénévolement la
voilà ces
âmes était calme on fait de belles
rencontres c'est vrai les ego bien sûr
c'est normal mais en fait je lis
rencontre tout de même c'est qu'elle
n'était pas d'accord toi tu étais
contente bah moi je pense que je suis un
peu comme gilles connu que ici c'est
vrai à cession au-delà que ce soir cette
émission c'est parce que vous arrive
mais sinon en vrai on est dans merde et
trois sur qui elle est surtout
un monde des gold fm à
être édifiés mais retient alors tiens un
autre membre du groupe abba la question
des noms mais
merci à radu avec moi chez les bons
deals et j'en ai marre
des gens critiquer la terreur qu'ils
sont et qu'ils font la télé à mon dégoût
oui comme dans tous les milieux un monde
et fermait la preuve que non c'est ça
fait trente ans qu'elle à l'antenne ya
plein de gens qui durant télé ceux qui
diraient ils sont mauvais mais c'est un
peu d'avenir furieux et ça il ya des
mauvais qui dure aussi c'est vrai il ya
des instances dans tous les milieux mais
qu'il y aura là et c'est un peu
insupportable de voir des gens qui sont
dans la télé dire oui c'est un milieu
insupportable aabar et vous si vous
n'êtes pas confirmé ces raids barbares
et vous paraît-elle au départ on dit pas
que ça monte à supportable mais l'ego
c'est vrai mais comment résister à l'ego
je parle pas de moi mais quand on voit
mal série commandée que je suis demandée
légaux janvier jouer il y aura beaucoup
de travail ou quand vous sortez le
travail et des gens qui vous attendent
dehors pour lui demander un autographe
vous applaudir etc vous felecite dans la
rue est entouré de suceurs de flatteurs
donc c'est normal qu'à un moment la tête
bon pour peu qu'on soit prêt mais
c'était à ça j'ai toujours eu le temps
de se battre non mais c'est vrai qu'il
ya beaucoup de gens font la queue qui me
parlent que d'eux dans les dîners ou
jeudi a fini deuxième des animateurs
c'est insupportable monsieur franchement
moi je fais pas dit la vérité non non
c'est pas ça c'est vrai vous ne venez
dîner je peux pas blairer ma gueule et
je peux pas de place donc les gens sont
obligés un peu de marché sur les autres
pour gad conserver leur place et écarter
les rivaux
c'est un monde qui est agréable pour m
géraldine qui met à mon petit niveau
parce que moi je suis pas une
professionnelle de la télé mais j'ai
fréquenté d'autres milieux la mode les
egos et surdimensionnés la littérature
alors je vous en parle
exactement
andré malraux pendant des semaines et
des semaines
c'est l'argent la notoriété et le
pouvoir en armant vous remuez ça et ça
ça crée des dessins et des mines amina
raison je moi je pense qu'il est encore
pire dans l'édition parce qu'en plus
j'ai le sentiment d'appartenir à une
élite intellectuelle
ce qui n'est pas le cas à la télé